FAUCI, CHIEF MEDICAL EXAMINER ON
CORONAVIRUS TO PRESIDENT BIDEN,
AND THE NATIONAL INSTITUTE OF
ALLERGIES AND INFECTIOUS
DISEASES.
DR. FAUCI, ALWAYS GOOD TO TALK
WITH YOU.
>> GOOD TO BE WITH YOU.
TOP OF MIND FOR MORE PARENTS,
KIDS ARE GOING BACK TO SCHOOL.
MANY HAVE BEEN BACK IN SCHOOL
FOR A COUPLE OF WEEKS NOW.
HOW MUCH SHOULD WE EXPECT AN
INCREASE IN INFECTIONS OF
CHILDREN UNDER 12 NOT YET
VACCINATED AS THEY GO BACK TO
SCHOOL, PARTICULARLY IN MANY
STATES WHERE THEY'RE NOT EVEN
ALLOWED TO REQUIRE MASKS FOR
INSTANCE IN SCHOOLS.
HOW CONCERNED ARE YOU?
>> THAT'S THE ISSUE THAT YOU
JUST MENTIONED, JIM, IF WE DO
THINGS RIGHT, WE HOPE WE DON'T
SEE MUCH INCREASE AT ALL.
IF WE WANT TO PROTECT THE
CHILDREN, PARTICULARLY THOSE WHO
ARE NOT YET ELIGIBLE FOR
VACCINATION, YOU WANT TO
SURROUND THE CHILDREN WITH
PEOPLE WHO ARE VACCINATED,
TEACHERS, SCHOOL PERSONNEL,
EVERYONE ELSE.
BUT ALSO IN ORDER TO PROTECT
THOSE WHO CAN'T GET VACCINATED.
THERE ARE CERTAIN SIMPLE THINGS
YOU HAVE TO DO.
YOU MENTIONED ONE OF THEM.
UNIVERSAL MASKING IN THE SCHOOL,
AND EVEN THOUGH THERE ARE, YOU
KNOW, SOME GOVERNMENT LEADERS
LOCALLY WHO ARE TRYING TO PUSH
BACK ON THAT, WE HAVE TO GET THE
SCHOOL SYSTEM MASKED, IN
ADDITION TO SURROUNDING THE
CHILDREN WITH VACCINATED PEOPLE.
THAT'S THE SOLUTION.
WE DON'T NEED TO SEE A BIG UP
TICK AT ALL IN CASES IF WE DO IT
RIGHT.
>> THE TROUBLE IS, AS YOU KNOW,
POLITICS STILL TRUMP THE
SCIENCE, RIGHT.
YOU LISTEN FOR INSTANCE TO THE
GOVERNOR OF FLORIDA, ONE OF THE
STATES OF COURSE THAT HAS BANNED
MASK MANDATES.
THE WAY HE DESCRIBED
VACCINATIONS WAS REALLY
REMARKABLE, AND AGAIN, DEFIES
THE SCIENCE.
I WANT TO PLAY IT NOW, JUST
DESCRIBING WHO THE VACCINE IS
FOR.
HAVE A LISTEN.
I WANT TO GET YOUR REACTION.
>> THE VACCINES HAVE HELPED
PEOPLE WARD OF SEVERE ILLNESS,
AND WE OBVIOUSLY WORK HARD TO
DISTRIBUTE IT.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, THOUGH,
IT IS ABOUT YOUR HEALTH AND
WHETHER YOU WANT THAT PROTECTION
OR NOT.
IT REALLY DOESN'T IMPACT ME OR
ANYONE ELSE.
>> THAT'S FALSE.
PLEASE EXPLAIN TO FOLKS WHY
THAT'S FALSE.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
WELL, I MEAN, I DIDN'T HEAR HIM
VERY WELL FROM THE SOUND, BUT, I
MEAN, IF HE FEELS THAT VACCINES
ARE NOT IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE,
THAT THEY ARE JUST IMPORTANT FOR
SOME PEOPLE.
THAT'S COMPLETELY INCORRECT.
VACCINATION, JIM, HAS BEEN THE
SOLUTION TO EVERY MAJOR PUBLIC
ISSUE IN WHICH A VACCINE WAS
DEVELOPED FOR.
I MEAN, SMALLPOX, POLIO,
MEASLES, I'M NOT SURE WHAT
PEOPLE ARE TALKING ABOUT WHEN
THEY PUSH BACK ON VACCINATIONS.
IT IS HISTORICALLY OVER DECADES
AND DECADES AND DECADES SHOWN TO
BE THE WAY YOU CONTROL AN
INFECTIOUS DISEASE.
>> BEYOND THAT, TO CLARIFY, HIS
POINT AT THE END THERE WAS TO
SAY, IT'S JUST A PERSONAL CHOICE
ABOUT YOURSELF.
IT DOESN'T IMPACT ANYBODY ELSE.
EXPLAIN WHY THAT'S JUST NOT
TRUE.
>> WELL, THAT'S NOT TRUE AT ALL.
I MEAN, OBVIOUSLY IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR YOU AS AN INDIVIDUAL, FOR
YOUR OWN PERSONAL PROTECTION,
SAFETY AND HEALTH.
BUT WHEN YOU HAVE A VIRUS THAT'S
CIRCULATING IN THE COMMUNITY,
AND YOU ARE NOT VACCINATED, YOU
ARE PART OF THE PROBLEM BECAUSE
YOU'RE ALLOWING YOURSELF TO BE A
VEHICLE FOR THE VIRUS TO BE
SPREADING TO SOMEONE ELSE.
SO IT ISN'T AS IF IT STOPS WITH
YOU.
IF THAT WERE THE CASE, THEN IT
WOULD BE ONLY ABOUT YOU.
BUT IT DOESN'T.
YOU CAN GET INFECTED EVEN IF YOU
GET NO SYMPTOMS OR MINIMALLY
SYMPTOMATIC AND PASS IT ON TO
SOMEONE WHO, IN FACT, MIGHT BE
VERY VULNERABLE, AN ELDERLY
PERSON, A PERSON WITH AN
UNDERLYING DISEASE, SO WHEN
YOU'RE DEALING WITH AN OUTBREAK
OF AN INFECTIOUS DISEASE, IT
ISN'T ONLY ABOUT YOU.
THERE'S A SOCIETAL
RESPONSIBILITY THAT WE ALL HAVE.
>> SAD FACT IS A LOT OF FOLKS
AREN'T MAKING CHOICES BASED ON
THAT SCIENCE OR THAT
RESPONSIBILITY TO OTHERS IN
THEIR COMMUNITY.
WE HAVE THE DELTA VARIANT.
IT HAS BEEN LEADING TO AN
INCREASED NUMBER, NOT JUST OF
INFECTIONS BUT CRUCIALLY DEATHS.
DO YOU ANTICIPATE THAT IN THE
COMING WEEKS THAT WILL TAIL OFF
AT ALL?
THAT THE FALL WILL BE WORSE, OR
IS IT POSSIBLE IT MIGHT BE
BETTER, THAT THOSE INCREASES,
WE'LL SEE THOSE GRAPHS KIND OF
COME OFF THESE PEAKS.
>> WELL, JIM, IT COULD GO EITHER
WAY, AND IT'S UP TO US.
WE HAVE THE CAPABILITY WITHIN
OUR OWN SELVES, OUR OWN DECISION
MAKING PROCESS, AS TO WHETHER OR
NOT WE WANT TO GO IN THE
DIRECTION OF DIMINUTION, WE CAN
DO THAT.
WE HAVE THE TOOL TO DO IT, WE
HAVE 75 MILLION PEOPLE IN THIS
COUNTRY WHO ARE ELIGIBLE TO BE
VACCINATED WHO ARE NOT YET
VACCINATED.
IF WE GET THE OVERWHELMING
MAJORITY OF THIS VACCINATED, WE
COULD TURN THIS AROUND EVEN AS
WE GO INTO THE COOLER WEATHER OF
THE FALL.
WE CAN DO IT.
IT'S WITHIN OUR GRASP.
>> LET ME ASK YOU THIS, BECAUSE
BEYOND THAT QUESTION OF GETTING
THE PORTION OF THE POPULATION,
ABOUT A QUARTER TO THIS POINT
WHO IS STILL NOT VACCINATED, YOU
NOW HAVE THIS QUESTION OF FOR
THE VACCINATED WHEN AND HOW
URGENTLY THEY MIGHT NEED A THIRD
SHOT.
I MEAN, WE'RE MOVING IN THAT
DIRECTION.
MY QUESTION IS WILL IT BECOME
THAT THIS IS REALLY NOT SO MUCH
A TWO-DOSE VACCINE, A PFIZER OR
MODERNA, BUT REALLY A
THREE-DOSE.
IN OTHER WORDS, YOU WILL NEED
THAT THIRD SHOT, THAT BOOSTER,
TO BE TRULY PROTECTED FROM THIS
VIRUS.
>> RIGHT.
I THINK THE LATTER.
GIVEN THE EXPERIENCE I HAVE OVER
THE MANY YEARS WITH VACCINES, IT
LOOKS VERY MUCH LIKE IT ISN'T AS
IF TWO DOSES OF A VACCINE ARE
FAILING, IT'S THAT THE PROPER
REGIMEN WILL VERY LIKELY AS WE
LOOK BACK ON IT MONTHS FROM NOW,
WILL BE THAT THREE DOSES IS
REALLY WHAT YOU SHOULD BE
GETTING OF AN mRNA.
THAT MIGHT BE TWO DOSES OF A
J&J, BUT FOR THE mRNA, WE KNOW
FROM STUDIES THAT ARE ALREADY
ONGOING IN ISRAEL THAT WHEN THE
DEGREE OF ATTENTION AGAINST
INFECTION OR SEVERE DISEASE GOES
DOWN TO A CERTAIN PRECARIOUS
LEVEL, WHEN YOU GIVE THE PERSON
THAT THIRD BOOST, YOU
DRAMATICALLY INCREASE THE LEVEL
OF PROTECTION.
EVEN MORE SO THAN BEFORE THE
BOOST.
IT GOES UP TO AND BEYOND THE
LEVEL OF PROTECTION.
I MEAN, I BELIEVE STRONGLY THAT
ULTIMATELY WE'RE GOING TO SEE
THAT AS PROPER REGIMEN, THREE
DOSES OF AN MRNA.
>> THE THIRD DOSE MAKES YOU MORE
PROTECTED.
TROUBLE HAS BEEN SOME MIXED
MESSAGING, MOVEMENT OF THE TIME
LINE ON WHEN THAT THIRD DOSE
WILL BE FULLY APPROVED.
I KNOW YOU HAVE SAID THAT YOU
STILL BELIEVE BY THE WEEK OF
SEPTEMBER 20th OR CLOSE THAT THE
WHITE HOUSE WILL BE ABLE TO MOVE
FORWARD ON ITS PLAN FOR BOOSTER
SHOTS, BUT GOVERNORS,
UNDERSTANDABLY FRUSTRATED ABOUT
SOME OF THIS GUIDANCE.
HAVE A LISTEN, I WANT TO GET
YOUR REACTION.
>> WE'VE GOT PEOPLE THAT ARE
WELL BEYOND SIX MONTHS THAT ARE
60 AND OLDER, THAT NEED THE
BOOSTER SHOT, AND WE CAN'T GIVE
IT TO THEM BECAUSE WE'RE BEING
HELD UP BY, YOU KNOW, THE NATION
AND ON THE FEDERAL LEVEL RIGHT
NOW.
>> WE NEED CLEAR GUIDANCE ON THE
BOOSTER SHOTS BECAUSE IT
UNDERMINES, YOU KNOW, THE
CREDIBILITY OF IT.
>> WHEN IN YOUR BEST GUEST, NOT
JUST GOVERNORS BUT FOLKS
WATCHING RIGHT NOW KNOW EXACTLY
WHEN AND WHAT BOOSTERS THEY WILL
GET AND SHOULD GET.
>> WELL, WE'RE STILL AIMING FOR
THE WEEK OF SEPTEMBER THE 20th.
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN OPTIMAL TO
GET AT LEAST WITH THE mRNA'S TO
GET BOTH PFIZER AND MODERNA TO
ROLL OUT THE BOOSTER PROGRAM AT
THE SAME TIME SIMULTANEOUSLY.
IT LOOKS NOW, IT IS POSSIBLE,
AND I THINK LIKELY, THAT YOU
WILL SEE PFIZER GET RULED OUT,
GET ROLLED OUT FIRST BECAUSE THE
DATA THAT THEY SUBMITTED TO THE
FDA.
REMEMBER, YOU'VE GOT TO GET
APPROVAL.
ALL OF THIS, JIM, AND WE SAID
THIS FROM THE VERY BEGINNING IS
CONTINGENT ON THE FDA REGULATORY
APPROVAL, AND THE RECOMMENDATION
OF THE ADVISORY COMMITTEE AND
IMMUNIZATION PRACTICES TO THE
CDC.
PFIZER HAS GOTTEN THOSE DATA
INTO THE FDA.
THEY'RE GOING OVER IT NOW.
I THINK THEY'RE GOING TO BE ON
TIME.
MODERNA MAY BE A BIT BEHIND BUT
NOT MUCH.
SO I THINK THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
GET BOTH OF THEM OUT.
THEY MAY NOT BE ABSOLUTELY
SIMULTANEOUSLY.
BUT IT'S GOING TO BE CLOSE.
>> BY THE END OF THIS MONTH.
>> I WOULD HOPE SO.
THEY'RE PROBABLY NO MORE THAN A
COUPLE OF WEEKS BEHIND, IF THAT
MUCH.
>> OKAY.
BIG PICTURE, THERE'S A QUESTION
NOW, YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH THIS,
ABOUT IS THERE A POINT WHERE WE
BEGIN TO LIVE WITH COVID-19 TO
SOME DEGREE, THAT IT BECOMES
LESS OF A PANDEMIC RESPONSE,
MORE OF WHAT'S KNOWN AS AN
ENDEMIC RESPONSE.
IT'S ONE OF MANY SEVERE
DISEASES, INFECTIONS WE LIVE
WITH.
ARE WE REACHING THAT POINT?
>> I THINK WE'RE GOING TO GET
THERE.
AS I SAID BEFORE, IN ANSWER TO
ONE OF YOUR OTHER QUESTIONS,
JIM, WE WILL GET THERE DEPENDING
ON HOW SUCCESSFULLY WE VACCINATE
OUR POPULATION.
IF WE GET MORE PEOPLE
VACCINATED, WE GIVE A BIG DENT
TO THE 75 MILLION PEOPLE WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE, NOT VACCINATED.
WE'LL TURN THIS AROUND FROM THE
STANDPOINT, YOU'RE NOT GOING TO
COMPLETELY ERADICATE IT.
RIGHT NOW, WE ARE IN OUTBREAK
MODE.
WE HAVE 160,000 INFECTIONS PER
DAY.
THAT'S A PANDEMIC.
WE CAN GET THAT WAY, WAY DOWN.
WE MAY NOT GET RID OF IT
COMPLETELY.
YOU MAY SEE INTERMITTENT CASES
THAT WILL COME AND BREAKTHROUGH,
WHICH WILL BE MANAGEABLE.
IT WILL NOT INTERFERE WITH OUR
LIVES.
IT WILL NOT BE A PUBLIC HEALTH
THREAT.
HOW SOON WE GET TH